so you went to film school answer me
yeah tumblr laughs I film directing come
dragon okay film Katti so how would feel
making me different for you and your
brother Wladimir if you were making
films a Serbian oh it's great question
and and you know service lots of lots of
talent and just look at the you know
tennis chart yeah but I'm wrong player
in the world you know and also film wise
you know when our directors the only guy
next to cope who went home with to
Pandora's I think there's Chanukah now
as well so there's to you but I'm very
talented people great people working
conditions different you know I'll never
forget and this was a sort of a school
for life my first short film student
film first day of shooting when the
streets of Belgrade and an hour into the
shooting they assassinate our prime
minister broad daylight now far from
where we were shooting and the whole
country stops and I that's why I learned
okay so there's a schedule and I want to
make a little movie but the world
doesn't care the reality has its own
thing going on and with that mindset I
learned like all right this is our
everyday I have to approach like you
know none of the days will be we're
making a movie and clouds opening us for
us it's you have to fight your way
through if you want to push that the
idea through that's what I took away
from circuit ah that's that's a major
mmm major life lesson right there what
lessons did you learn from film school
that were actually very true in the
Serbian school that you went to versus
what they teach you here and vice versa
what are some of the misconceptions
maybe that are in Serbia and then also
what are some of the realities that they
taught you that you don't see taught
here and maybe should be taught mmm you
know a lot of history in Serbia and they
do professor tend to cling on to the
history aspect of films and you know
just kind of dig from the past thing
from the past
while here in a lot of aspects people
look into the future a lot you know so
it's an interesting interesting for me
lees that was the experience you know
kind of like I spoke to the filmmakers
hearing they're like this is what's
going to be done in the next five years
and this is how them films going to be
done over there you know here's a great
day said the guy made a film in you know
1963 and this is how it should be done I
don't know it was that the relationship
to the history I think it's a bit
different so the Americans saying that
the more things change the more things
stay the same kind of thing some supply
maybe in their curriculum versus here
and there the thought of you know in the
1990s everyone's going to be driving you
know flying cars it is what you so
people may be due to much forecasting
here you think you know it could be a I
was looking at the that theoretical
physicist the japanese guy dr Kaku I
don't know if you know what I'm talking
to fascinating a high fascinating things
talking about the future and what's
possible and where the physics what the
doors are physics is opening and it's
really interesting maybe it's really
inspiring but I did notice that that
link with history is a bit more applied
in at least I come from interesting hmm
do you wish you'd gone to film school
here as well I knew because of the whole
idea about the California campus and me
with flip flops sitting on the you know
the grass over in the book that for me
my brother went to school here Oh in
California yeah he went for years he was
the first guy in his school there was a
knack he was an academic scholarship
basketball scholarship was the first
basketball scholarship guy could fail to
school on time you know he did the
international business and managing them
without him this film wouldn't have
happened he's the producer and he just
jumped in like nobody else in this from
a cannonball you know do car loans
but uh but yeah he had that experience
and I did visit his campus and I was
like that was it for like we you know we
smoked cigarettes in our classrooms in
Serbia and yeah that was my fellow
school different
you